sur la plage de jullouville les pins en
normandie la colonie de vacances de la
ville de saint-ouen parmi 300 enfants un
petit garçon comme les autres voici sa
journée à la colo
[Musique]
non
il
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous postez musée toilettes lionel qui
m'a écran et plats boucher j'en avais
plein figure 2
[Musique]
puis décroît seul
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous c'est plus dur en sont tous parce
que ils ignorent qu'ils vont faire nous
qu'ils ont démoli l et es salaam
dans les lots ils vont mettre une eau
propre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les besoins de tous de grands
noms
[Musique]
prendre note du pays
pourrait être
contraint
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
s'affrontent
parce que c'est ça
est-ce que ce soit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et comment est amusant
jammie thomas d'un grand bâtiment poule
allait durer ça fait bien pris deux mois
au moins
au futur il en faut trois bâtiments pic
de garage
puis des boutiques des secrets
tu vois je cachais football
tu as des frères tu avais soeur on est
une serre où grande qu'elle a une grande
soeur on me donnait une plus grande la
grande cage et 27 en pis longtin 18 ans
quel homme ou petit frère et d'un bail à
4 one minoui précise annie
japonais géo ses marges et
les kings alors tu viendras moi j'aurai
dans la voiture à toit effondré martyrs
bientôt s'y
est ce qu'il fait on pas un rider coelho
il fait des petits les petits
ne s'est pas des petits moutons ou
coupons mais la vitesse sont qu'amour
alors elles mêmes qui la mienne thil qui
vous tombe pile-poil appuyer dessus
le camion il a créé ainsi une bien
pauvre
mais je tousse c'est lui qui travaille
tour il fait travailler les autres ce
type aux quelque trente temps en temps
en temps mais aussi beaucoup
pierre ans il avait trente six ont un
moment il a ainsi invité en utilisant la
ne pouvait pas voir précisant que
maintenant 30 ans
oui
il avait 30 ans mais moins de 6 ans
[Musique]
parce que tu préfères côté vacances
étaient pas faire être ici opacité à
saint-ouen je pense à toi j'aime
colonies devenues
leurs vacances que mieux puisque c'est
le bleu neige qui tombent tous les jours
en été
oui mais aussi la neige tombe tu aimes
bien la neige oui c'est bien fait d vous
le pis les entrées de quelques uns des
fois à l'hôtel claridge
qu'est ce que tu préfères c'est la neige
ou bien d'être ici au bord de la mer
[Musique]
écolo mais bien parce que on est chez
bofa n'est ce qu'on veut faire une
grande cote 1 c'est là où je creuse ses
montagnes alors un montagne quand je
descends tu vois mes cousins
et alors on va par là puis la semaine
mon peuple ils abouti qu'à répandre
des fois je vais à la boutique tout seul
j'ai pas peur du pot
et un pot avec une petite rue viennent
alors moi je prends peur du compte l'os
n'est pas sérieux blanc à 12h
tu vas aller chercher du lait voyage
viennent chercher refuge connu un gros
paquet de fer que plus j'achète des
bobos qui en fait à côté et pour qui tu
achète tout ça
[Musique]
ici mais ça c'est pas mal c'est pas ma
maman c'est pas ma vraie maman sassine
il m'a mois celle là c'est la vraie
monnaie et donc c'est peut être parce
que je vis al-mabhouh
c'était
[Musique]
dans mon
papa il avait javier grands confrères
une grande soeur martine et
trop de ciseaux
[Musique]
le garçon est bien
quand même temps
c'est plus que
46 ans quand
alors
une mais
[Musique]
c'est pas parce que mon papa je crois
qu'il a lille il aurait mieux fait pas
du tout le monde et qu'ils
hamon et jaurès
[Musique]
les bateaux qui pensent qu'ils font
oui les bois 1
et d'ailleurs une fois j'ai vu un film
c'est quoi ce rigolo ça rigolo non je
bouge et c'est pas écolo parce que
j'aime et qui monte sur la toile il
pleuvait et il pleuvait mois irrite ont
fait le bateau fosses de sable il y en a
eu tombé dans l'eau s'est nourrie
par sa femme a dit m
[Musique]
côté jaune
ça s'appelle un cahier petit jeu c'est
ça que vous connaissez ça où tout est
toujours là mais il ya un petit chemin
seulement tout drôle niveau c'est pour
du ruisseau un droit chine
a montré pays il ya des escaliers pont
qui
gérait tout
[Musique]
il ya des joueurs au pij avis et
voitures de course been grosse voiture
le conseil blé
qu'est ce que tu penses à l'économie
c'est bien
tiens
c'est dans ce cadre là même dans ce
qu'ils ont fait le poil c'est quoi
[Applaudissements]
la rue comme ce qui fait du bien aux
comics open c'est oui
puis des copines j'applique le moment
mais que j'ai mangé des mobo parce que
gêné j'en ai eu à la coopérative qui
parce que c'est les copains artistes les
bonbons
m
ouais
là
allez
les invités à utiliser partout et
toujours
moins de sept pages d'or votre pareils
de la laine pour vous le travail sur yon
l'eau et le feu
merci mes amis ni un soir que le prince
était tout seul dans sa chambre il vit
entrer un je leur ai alors il frappait
tout il faut appeler vieux parce qu'ils
iter
impôts cri pour quoi faire
pur jus oui à notre petite rivière c'est
une petite rivière pis la petite rue via
jusqu à côté du château au prince noir
alors après les
tous les hypocrites devant la vue des
chiens qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait et ba
ils ont fui vous savez trio fui et là
sur son cheval le vin le noir qu'est ce
qu'il emmenait
le prince harry
bien
et ben maintenant on va aller se coucher
[Musique]
jb recherche on a reçu ta petite laide
et vieille qui nous a fait perdre et
nous sommes bien pratique amuse bien et
on sait que tu vas te baigner dans ton
genre et venues passer la journée avec
lui on a parlé de toi que tu namibien
[Musique]